[Music]
imagine spending 2100 hours
working on a project this account is you
can see at the top right this recording
to look really scuffed is aussie nam
died this is a hardcore i've been
working on for literally
since just before room fest october for
12 hours a day you're sitting at your
computer
chipping away at a passion project that
you've poured your heart and soul into
two in a day let's get the defender out
of the way
and then just like that 87 days
almost three months of non-stop work
gone in an instant
wait what what did i do
that's exactly what happened to bodhi
one of the most
popular runescape content creators
around oh my god
it's actually my one my body dropped the
armor on the ground
it's my dragon ball i'm a baby yeah
why did i have to tank suck
that's why you eat cauliflower that way
bro could you get a basilisk
off and there we go ladies and gentlemen
that is it i'm never going to kill the
minions we're going to pick up our coins
and we're going to get out of there
we're done rank 1 garado 1
337 kill count oh that's so
good bill the sanguine nasty
stuff dude that is amazing that is
very very very good
when it comes to runescape bodhi is an
og content creator known for being a bit
of a lovable [ __ ]
and for having a hilariously twisted
relationship with his community
ladies and gentlemen the streamer
including the tax reform sorry the
freaking student loan received 32
000 pounds from the hmrc today my boys
so
shoes canceled [ __ ] you all don't need
any of you i'm going casino boys i will
see you all later
have a good run peace out morons you all
suck
and if you didn't know runescape's an
almost 20 year old point-and-click rpg
where you level up your character
complete quests and you know kill [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
so dumb this game is so trash
i'm playing roller coasters i cannot
even care anymore
and for the past six years bodhi has
been running what's known as a hardcore
ironman account and the whole idea is is
that you only have
one life you get no help from your
friends and if you
die that's it there's no do-overs as an
iron man you cannot trade another player
meaning those supplies you need for that
quest or clue scroll will have to be
collected by yourself
and monster kills don't count unless
you've done 100 of the damage yourself
it's the true test of in-game knowledge
efficiency and independence
well hardcore iron man is all that and
more stepping it up a notch it means you
have one life and one life alone to
accomplish all of your goals
to be clear if you die it's not like
developer jagex deletes your account or
some [ __ ] but it does mean that your
hardcore status goes out the window
and you can no longer contribute to
hardcore leaderboards
and for guys like bodhi and other
content creators that status
means everything leading up to bodhi's
infamous mistake
his streams were hilarious whether it
was him getting griefed in game
losing to random number generators or
just eating kiwis
today we have a kiwi with the skin on
and we're going to be garnishing this
kiwi with vinegar bro it's going to be
beautiful look at that man
yeah oh yeah that was good that was the
best kiwi
i've ever been in my life i'm really
happy about it
i'm happy that i did you know
sorry i swallowed no i just want to keep
it the back of my nose
oh and over the decade that he's spent
streaming runescape he's developed
let's call it a unique relationship with
his chat
as in he bans people left right and
center you win question mark t brawler
sure
you're not playing 10 days in the cage
i'll win the game in my own time you've
got 10 days and i won the game anyway
band for the truth right there guys
it's gotten to the point now where it's
this weird badge of honor to get banned
by bodhi
and you never know what's gonna set him
off it could be a small miscalculation
how are you gonna say you're trying to
kill a hundred banner skills but then be
fried after like kill 37. so corona cake
you're now permanently banned
yeah you've mentioned that i did 37
grotto kills today
chad how many kills did i do today it
was 36.8
or by simply piping up
[Music]
myself in sancho why is he a streamer
i don't know why i don't know who he is
i'm arrogant
he's a league streamer grand ego mate
you're on seven hours go away that
honestly in a
on a different day that would have been
a permanent man without any question you
all know that wouldn't have been a
permanent but
you all know that would have been a
permanent man in my defense sir
i don't actually watch any league of
legends but that would have been a perm
ban to anyone but you shall
now while bodhi might have this
asshole-ish demeanor that plays out in
weird ways live on stream
he's actually a giant sweetheart in the
past he's upgraded smaller
streamer setups whether it's a new mic
mixer or
a complete overhaul and one of the
craziest examples of bodhi's dope
demeanor is when he pledged to donate
thousands of dollars to the runescape
community if they could beat a record
held by another player who goes by the
name of
exact so to celebrate ten thousand
subscribers i am offering
ten thousand dollars from me to any
runescape player
who can beat x zach's inferno uh
combat cape anyone that can beat that
cape 46 combat
it's possible ten thousand dollars the
rules you have to stream you've gotta
stream the actual
zuck fight the only rule on his most
recent account running a character named
ozzy nam died bodhi put in roughly 2100
hours of work that's almost three months
of grinding
87 and a half days of being perfect at
one of the most difficult modes
in an already obtuse game and with one
miss click
chat watched in gleeful horror as his
hardcore
status went out the [ __ ] window but
let's back up a second
when bodhi first started this hardcore
account he didn't know what to expect
and neither did the thousands of people
who tuned in to watch
[Music]
that's why you eat cauliflower that way
bro could you get a basilisk jaw
you know done done another grind
completed in
12 seconds this counts great bro one
month turned into two
two into four and before he knew it
bodhi had gone
nine months playing ozzy nam died
without dying
for nine months bodhi kept his character
alive
overcoming some of the game's most
difficult obstacles
time and time again
why did i have the tongue
sure bodhi is insanely talented but he's
also insanely lucky almost dying on
three separate
occasions the instant dc on that sounds
like i'm just disconnected though
that could actually be the end of my
hardcore again to a disconnection which
will suck
don't you dare like being dead i'll be
so upset
oh my freaking god oh my god
oh my god oh my christ how is that
right relax holy [ __ ] in christ how am i
alive
but then in a tragic twist of fate bodhi
went to the bathroom
yo mr
four five five 95980-11-235-8132-134552
three five seven one one thank you dude
for the prime i appreciate it
nine months of work vanished because
bodhi grazed his mouse when he got up to
take a piss are you kidding me
are you freaking joking me how is that
possible how do you die that way
that stings bro
that is i mean i had a feeling i was
gonna die
in the most dumb way i really had that
feeling
and i do not know how it could be any
dumber than that
the death of his character ozzy nam died
left bodhi feeling demotivated and
wanting to take a break from streaming
and playing runescape
but he wasn't done just yet because the
same day that ozzy nam
died died bodhi signed up to do some
sponsored streams
guys uh i am sponsored my dearest
friends by pokestars now these contracts
were signed
like you can all giggle here these
contracts were signed the day i died on
my hardcore which is really annoying
um because i don't really have any plans
to stream
um but obviously i'm now obligated to
play some poke which is fine because i
don't have to play runescape so it's
more along the lines of
i don't have to play runescape but once
he completed his sponsorship obligations
bodhi dipped
he took a two month long break from both
streaming and playing runescape
leaving viewers to wonder when he'd be
back to personally eat them from his
chat
but come september bodhi returned both
with a new hardcore account
and a good cause to support first things
first i haven't streamed in about 50
days
and i have 2 000 subscribers so between
now
september the 4th and october
freaking 4th i guess i'm donating my
whatever my twitch paycheck is
i'm donating all of it to charity let's
just hope this time
he's a little more careful when he gets
up my question have i just set the most
very good death of all time
like like a freaking alfie's iron dragon
[ __ ] i generally think my legacy is not
stop that like that is